das ist wirklich rätselhaft es gibt
nicht wenige schwarze löcher die viel zu
schwer sind um aus normalen sternen
entstanden zu sein wie also kommt es zu
solchen masse giganten fachleute
weltweit versuchen dafür eine erklärung
zu finden und das scheint einem
forschungsteam aus den usa jetzt endlich
gelungen zu sein und das spannende ist
dass wo und das wie fix um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity klocke nur dann
verpasst er nicht mehr los geht's
herzlich willkommen
es geht beispielsweise um das ereignis
wird der bezeichnung gw 17 07 29 hierbei
handelt es sich um eine sehr weit
entfernte und massereiche quelle von
gravitationswellen vor etwa fünf
milliarden jahren fand ihr eine
verschmelzung statt bei der fast fünf
sonnenmassen in gravitationswellen
umgewandelt wurden aufgespürt werden
solche gravitationswellen von den
detektoren lego und wirkung
mittlerweile konnten seit dem ersten
nachweis von gravitationswellen schon
zehn verschmelzungen schwarze ritter
aufgezeichnet werden und zudem sogar
auch noch eine kollision von zwei
neutronenstern doch das große rätsel
dreht sich um die massen der schwarzen
löcher die an solchen verschmelzungen
beteiligt sind denn klar ist bei dem
ereignis gw 17 07 29 war mindestens ein
schwarzes loch mit 58,6 sonnenmassen
beteiligt doch wie kommt solch einen
extremen massereiches schwarzes loch zu
stande
fachleute wissen dass solche masse
gigant niemals aus einem stern kollaps
hervorgehen könnte denn dann hätte der
entsprechende stern schon weit vor dem
erreichen dieser ausgangs masse
kollabieren müssen ein us forschungsteam
hat sich dieses rätsel genauer
angeschaut und in einer simulation
analysiert und so ist es den fachleuten
tatsächlich gelungen die entstehung
dieser extremen masse giganten zu
erklären der neuen studie zufolge fängt
das umfeld von aktiven galaxienkernen
schwarze löcher ein und lässt diese in
serie miteinander verschmelzen so kommt
es zu der außergewöhnlich großen masse
dieser objekte
das autorenteam beschreibt das mögliche
szenario folgendermaßen demnach sammelt
sich im umfeld eines aktiven
supermassereichen schwarzen lochs im
galaxienkernen einiges an mit dabei
ganze sterne eine gigantische scheibe
aus heißem gas
allen der materie und stellare schwarze
löcher all das kreist aufgrund der
anziehungskraft in der nachbarschaft des
massen giganten herum die kleineren
schwarzen löcher befinden sich auf einer
sehr engen bahn und haben keine chance
zu entkommen
dazu im privathaus der an der studie
beteiligt war das ist wie bei einem
hurrikan um dessen auge alles kreist nur
dass das auge in diesem fall ein ring um
das zentrale supermassereiche schwarze
loch ist es kommt zu zahlreichen
verschmelzungen denn in diesem ring wie
die fachleute schreiben treffen sich
immer mehr die gefangenen schwarzen
löcher es finden also kollisionen in
serie statt das ergebnis liege auf der
hand ein außergewöhnlich massereiches
ereignis wie beispielsweise gw 17 07 29
dazu schreibt das autorenteam in der
aktuellen studie solche hierarchischen
verschmelzungen sind in migrations
fallen der aktiven galaxienkerne eher
die regel als die ausnahme sie
resultieren aus einer kette von
aufeinanderfolgenden verschmelzungen in
rund 40 prozent der beobachteten fälle
wären dann eines der schwarzen löcher
schwerer als 50 sonnenmassen die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind überzeugt davon dass ihre erklärung
für die entstehung dieser masse giganten
die richtige ist ihre analyse zufolge
ist sie fünf mal wahrscheinlicher als
andere mögliche szenarien die die
ungewöhnliche masse erklären wollen
stützen würde ihre theorie auch durch
die beobachtung dass extrem schwere
schwarze löcher sehr schnell rotieren
denn auch das war in ihrer simulation
die folge dieser verschmelzung in serie
wie sieht ein schwarzes loch aus
anklicken anschauen und vor allem
breaking lab abonnieren super kanal und
er ist kurz 200.000 am bus nur ein paar
fehlen noch und der silberne play button
ist unterwegs also bis dann bleibt dran